>> Male Presenter: Good afternoon everyone.
Thank you for coming.
We are in the Google Los Angeles office today.
This presentation is brought to you by the
Authors at Google team.
To everyone in the room and watching on YouTube,
thank you so much for watching.
It is my honor and privilege to introduce
to you food-blogger and very successful cookbook
author, Gabi Moskowitz.
We--.
I met Gabi in, I guess, in 2000 in Boston,
Massachusetts where we both went to school.
And we both collaborated on some very inspired
fraternity party planning.
[laughs] And since then, she's moved to San
Francisco where she was a kindergarten teacher
for a short time and fell into professional
cooking, professional catering and started
a blog called "The BrokeAss Gourmet."
>> Gabi Moskowitz: BrokeAss Gourmet.
>> Male Presenter: You can find it at BrokeAss
Gourmet dot com.
And since then she has published the "BrokeAss
Gourmet" cookbook.
And she will be demonstrating a recipe for
us today.
So, Gabi, here ya go.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: Thanks Benji.
I actually--.
[applause]
Thank you.
This is so fun.
So as Benji said my name is Gabi.
And I am a professional food blogger.
And I just wrote my first book, "the brokeass
gourmet cookbook."
The deal with brokeass gourmet is that all
the recipes cost less than 20 bucks to make.
And it's not just how to avoid starvation
dot com.
It's really how to eat well.
How to eat restaurant inspired gourmet food
without spending a lot of money.
The genesis of the blog happened when I was
living in San Francisco in 2008.
And in fall of 2008, the bottom fell out of
the economy.
And I noticed this trend.
I had all of these friends who had jobs at
places like Google or Facebook.
And they were working crazy hours.
They'd gotten these jobs right out of college.
And they were fed as you guys are, breakfast,
lunch, and dinner.
And snacks if they need.
And in the process hadn't developed any sort
of domestic skills.
So, when they lost their jobs and their incomes,
suddenly they found themselves eating a whole
lot of frozen burritos.
And that just made me sad because I grew up
learning how to cook.
My parents taught me how.
It was a big part of my life.
And then, when I was a teacher on a very meager
salary I had to really learn how to make ends
meet.
But I grew up in Sonoma County.
And so, eating well was always a really big
priority for me.
So, BrokeAss Gourmet really came from a place
of wanting to teach my peers and everybody
else that eating well is not that hard to
do.
And being able to afford great food is not
hard either.
So, the book really focuses on that.
It's sort of a primer for people who are new
to the kitchen.
But it's also great for more experience cooks
who are trying to really streamline their
food.
The backbone of the blog and the book is what
I call the 50 dollar pantry.
It’s 50 dollars’ worth of things that
you need to have at all times.
And you add a few fresh ingredients and then
you've got a real meal.
So, sort of basics for setting up your pantry.
I've also got how to set up a budget bar,
how to create a basic shopping list, that
kind of stuff.
And I think it's really great for people who
are just starting or, as I said, people who
are trying to streamline their cooking.
So, today I'm going to be making one of my
favorite appetizers, Vietnamese spring rolls
with peanut sauce.
I'm doing a vegetarian version.
But this is one of those things that is so
cheap.
Especially if you live near a good Asian specialty
grocery store.
You could find everything involved so inexpensively.
And it's one of those things that people take
a bite of and they're so impressed with you.
And that's the other piece of it.
I really like getting credit for things that
weren't that hard to do.
And this is a really good example of that.
So, anyway, we're gonna get started.
And the peanut sauce for the record is one
of the yummiest things you can make.
I like to make a big thing of it in the beginning
of the week and just use it in lots of different
ways.
I'll pour it over noodles, vegetables.
It's really good over grilled salmon.
It's great as a dip with crudités.
You know, cut up some carrots and celery,
bell peppers and just serve it like that.
And the spring rolls are basically the perfect
accompaniment for it.
So, I'm gonna get started.
And they are a few ingredients here that you
can take or leave or swap out for something
different.
So, for example, I love cilantro, but I know
not everyone does.
So, if you don't love cilantro, you can either
skip it, you could use finely chopped scallions
or chives, or even a little flat leaf parsley.
Give it a nice kick.
But I'm gonna use it today.
And the other thing that some people don't
love is the Sriracha.
So, if you're not a spicy person, just skip
it.
So, I'm starting with just some basic creamy
peanut butter.
[clanking noise] The recipe is obviously in
the book so I'm not gonna talk about amounts.
[clanking noise] Peanut butter is a pantry
ingredient.
Something I include on the 50 dollar pantry
list because it is one of those things that
is relatively inexpensive, it's high protein,
and it can be used a whole bunch of different
ways.
So, that's there.
[clanking noise] This is coconut milk.
Coconut milk comes in a can.
It's not very expensive.
[mixing noise] I highly recommend buying the
kinds that are imported from Thailand or Vietnam.
But any kind will work.
I don't like to use light coconut milk because
I find it to be too watery.
But if that's your preference then it can
certainly be substituted.
[dish clanging] And this is gonna give the
peanut sauce a really creamy consistency and
it's gonna blend with the peanut butter to
make a really nice base for the sauce.
Then I've got some honey.
And my--.
I call for honey in this recipe but brown
sugar would also work.
Even white sugar, agave nectar.
If you're avoiding sugar then something like
Splenda would work or stevia.
It's really important to balance flavors.
So, we've got some sweet.
We've got, the peanut butter's a little bit
savory.
We're gonna have some more savory things.
This is some fresh lime juice.
And limes are so cheap I really recommend
against buying the bottled kind.
It's so much better to just get a fresh lime.
And this is gonna add some of the tartness
to the sauce.
And then, I would say, maybe 95 percent of
good savory food requires garlic.
So of course we're gonna get that in there.
I've also got some rice vinegar.
If you were making this and you didn't have
rice vinegar, you could add an extra lime.
You could add a little white vinegar.
I would recommend against balsamic 'cause
it's a little too heavy in flavor.
But any sort of white vinegar.
I have made it it with champagne vinegar or
even white balsamic will work in a pinch.
Alright, then I've got some soy sauce which
is another important pantry ingredient.
Soy sauce helps take care of that umami flavor.
And it just brings a lot of that depth of
flavor without costing a whole lot.
[coughing]
I've also got some fresh ginger.
A really important principle of BrokeAss cooking
is to use fresh, fresh things like herbs and
spice.
Because a container of dry ginger first of
all, won't provide much of an impact of flavor.
And it will cost a lot more than buying a
big chunk of fresh ginger.
So, this, I think, is much more worth it.
We're gonna get that in.
OK.
And then I got some Sriracha.
You could also use something like Sambal.
Any sort of Asian chili sauce.
I've even done it before with Tabasco.
You just want to get some fire in there.
Even fresh jalapeños will work.
And it's really easy.
Just put this on.
And it's gonna be a little loud.
[blender noise] Alright, and I'm gonna add
some fresh cilantro, now that we've got it
nice and smooth.
Because this is a Vitamix, I guess I could
have put it all in but my food processor at
home is not quite as powerful.
[blender noise] There we go.
Alright.
So, just gonna grab one of these.
And when you serve it, I like to go like this.
You eat with your eyes first, as I am sure
you know.
And when you're not spending a lot of money
on groceries it’s nice to go that extra
step to make the way your food looks a little
special.
So, we're gonna do that with a spiral today.
And that is peanut sauce.
Set that there for now.
And now we're gonna make the spring rolls.
And these are one of the most fun things to
do with a group.
Sometimes I like to have--.
I'll have a spring roll and pot sticker party.
And I'll put out all the wrappers and fillings
and everyone can--.
Everyone hangs out and rolls them together.
And that's a really cool way to get people
together.
To get them interacting with their food, you
can do the same thing with a sushi party.
So, the base of Vietnamese spring roll is
these things.
And these can be found at most Whole Foods
stores.
I don't know the Los Angeles grocery store
scene very well.
So I'm not sure if you can get this at something
like Ralph's but definitely Whole Foods.
Any sort of--.
Definitely any Asian grocery supply store.
And I would say probably most organic focused
health foods stores carry these.
They're like a dollar ninety nine at most
for a package of 30 or 40.
And they're basically just rice, really fine
ground rice, and water.
So, fillings I am going to be using today
are vegetarian.
But the possibilities are limitless when it
comes to Vietnamese spring rolls.
You could add--.
I've done it with grilled chicken and avocado
before.
I do a really nice one with raw salmon and
mango and some fresh mint.
That's really delicious.
You can go more of a traditional route and
do grilled pork and shrimp.
That's great.
Avocado's always really good.
Today I'm just going to be doing some really
basic vegetables and that helps keep it inexpensive.
Makes a really nice lunch.
So, it takes a little practice to figure out
how to do this.
But once you get it, it's really not that
hard.
You wanna dip this disk of rice stuff into
lukewarm water.
You don't want it to be too hot or then it
will just fall apart in your hands.
So, you can see it's already starting to become
more pliable.
So I'm just gonna set it down on a clean dry
surface.
And on the bottom, I'm gonna put some fresh
mint leaves.
And it creates sort of a stained glass look
by pressing them, placing them face down like
this so that they're facing out.
So go like that.
And as you can see all these veggies that
I have, have been sliced thinly and they're
all about the same size.
And that is really gonna help.
So, over here I've got some really thinly
sliced scallions.
And the chef did an awesome job with this.
These are even thinner than I usually do them
at home.
Usually you could just cut a scallion into--.
Like a chunk of scallion into three or four
slices and it works just fine.
But this is beautiful.
So, rearrange it like that going in the same
order.
And I'm just gonna pick up some of these carrot
matchsticks.
And if you do not feel like cutting your own
carrot matchsticks, the pre-bagged kind that
you get at Trader Joe's or most grocery stores
in the prepared produce section, that will
work fine.
A little bit more expensive but if you don't
feel like shredding a ton of carrots it might
be worth it.
Then I've got some bell peppers that are gonna
go in the same direction.
And some cucumber, a really nice substitution
for the cucumber is jicama.
So, then, you just tuck in the edges and then
the trick here is to fold it up really tightly.
[coughing]
There's a spring roll.
And this is the most fun part.
Slice it in half and you have this beautiful
little mosaic of vegetarian deliciousness.
So, I'm just gonna do a few of these and arrange
them on this platter just to give you an idea.
And I think we actually have some to taste.
Are those back there?
Do we maybe wanna pass them around?
So, we've got some peanut sauce and some spring
rolls to taste.
And I'm just gonna make a couple more.
Another great filling if you are doing these
for a party, is to buy--.
Places like Costco or other big bulk stores
sell actually really decent premade pulled
pork.
There's like a Niman Ranch pulled pork that's
pretty inexpensive considering the amount
you get.
And that makes a nice filling for something
like this.
If you wanna go a little bit less traditional.
I'll just do one more and show you what it
looks like.
And the trick is really not to let this get
too wet 'cause then it gets really hard to
work with.
>>male #1: Got a super yummy peanut sauce.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: Oh really?
Good.
I'm glad you like it.
It's really like crack peanut sauce.
It's so good.
>> male #2: It is like crack.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: [laughs] Alright, So, I
would just go like that and add some peanut
sauce and maybe take a little fresh cilantro.
And then if you're feeling really--.
Like you're into molecular gastronomy or something,
which I am totally not.
But I have a lot of respect for it.
Maybe do something fancy like that.
And for just a few bucks you have a really
cool, easy appetizer.
[applause]
Thank you.
>>male #3: Could you list a few of the other
things that are on your 50 dollar--.
Things you should have in your pantry list.
>>Gabi Moskowitz: Do I have the list?
>> male #3: Yeah.
Can you name a few of the other ones besides--.
>>Gabi Moskowitz: Yeah.
Sure.
All-purpose flour, extra virgin olive oil.
And in the book I actually talk about some
of the extra virgin olive oils that are a
good bargain out there.
Because I really don't think, I really don't
think you should be buying crappy bleached
flour or bottom of the barrel olive oil.
I think that you should be buying quality
things.
But you don't have to spend a lot of money.
So, I include some tips on that.
Things like baking powder, baking soda, and
kosher salt, and black pepper.
Things that you'd be really surprised a lot
of people don't think of.
Those are some of the basics.
Let's see, mayonnaise is another great one.
Because a cool trick to do with mayonnaise
is to make a quick aioli with a variety of
things.
Just toss it in a blender or even whisk it
together with some chopped garlic and a little
lemon juice and salt and pepper.
Or my favorite is mayonnaise and Sriracha
together.
Eat it with sweet potato fries and it's unbelievable.
Those are some examples.
>> male #4: Where do you get the inspiration
for your recipes?
>> Gabi Moskowitz: My inspiration?
So, I live in San Francisco in the Mission
District.
I don't know if anyone knows that area but
it's turned into a culinary mecca slash ghetto.
[laughs] It's awesome.
I live right by Delores Park and 18th street.
There's this--.
There's just restaurant after restaurant.
Full of inspiration.
So, one of my favorite things to do is to
go during happy hour when a lot of times small
plates are offered at a reduced price.
And taste things and get inspiration.
I'll make notes.
And I also read other blogs constantly and
cookbooks.
I watch not that much food TV.
I'm not really that into reality television.
But I do love watching things like Iron Chef
sometimes you can get a lot of ideas there.
But mostly from restaurants.
>> male #5: What are your top five restaurants
in Los Angeles?
>> Gabi Moskowitz: I don't know.
[laughs] I don't know.
I love--.
There's this place, I think it's around here
called Gialina.
An Italian spot.
Gialina.
That's great.
I really don't know the L.A. restaurant scene.
I could tell you--.
>> male #5: What about San Francisco?
>> Gabi Moskowitz: San Francisco, OK.
Let's see, there was this wonderful Pakistani
restaurant that just closed called, Lahore
Karahi.
But the guy who owned it is going to be opening
up another one.
And it was this hole in the wall but for nine
or ten dollars a person you could eat incredibly
well.
I live very close to a great restaurant called
Delfina on 18th street,
[coughing]
In San Francisco.
And it is outrageous and it has amazing pizza.
We're sort of--.
There's a big pizza trend right now in San
Francisco.
Everybody's trying to outdo each other with
wood burning pizza.
Wood burning stove pizza.
So, that's definitely up there.
There's this sushi spot at 16th and Valencia
in San Francisco called, Sushi Yo-Yo.
And it's another one of those magical gems
where you can get incredibly fresh fish, really
innovative rolls, and things like that for
not a lot of money.
It doesn't look like much, but you go in and
it's great.
One of my favorite gastro pubs is this place
called The Monk's Kettle.
That's an awesome spot.
And-- Oh and then there's this nameless dim-sum
place on Clemens Street.
I don't know what it's called, but it's directly
across the street from Green Apple Books.
>> male #6: First of all you've ruined peanut
sauce.
It was the best kept secret.
It's so easy to make and now everybody knows
about it.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: Awesome.
>> male #6: That was like my favorite go to.
Now the secret's out.
So, I love cooking and one thing that I just
can't master is making my own pizza dough.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: Oh.
>> male #6: Do you have a kitchen nemesis
that you just can't--.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: No.
OK.
Well first of all I have a second book coming
out and it's all about things to do with pizza
dough.
You should check out my pizza dough recipe
because it's awesome.
It really is, I get that it's tricky but I
have a really simple recipe.
Check it out.
So, that's the first thing.
Do I have a kitchen nemesis?
I did and you can read about it in the book.
It took me a really long time to get homemade
mayonnaise down.
And so, I tell a story in the book, I don't
think I include this detail which I'm about
to share which is that, the most, well, not
the most recent time I made it.
But I tell a particular story about a time
when, it was like a week after I had been
unceremoniously dumped, and I 'm standing
in my kitchen and I'm making, I'm trying to
make aioli for my blog.
'Cause I'm trying to distract myself with
work and it's not working and it looks just
like it had every other time I made it.
A useless pile of oil and eggs with a few
drops of vinegar.
But the cool thing about when you have a kitchen
nemesis, which I have learned, is that you
can Google whatever it is you're trying to
make.
Thanks for that by the way guys, I really
appreciate it.
[laughter]
And there are forums.
There are forums on everything.
So, I bet if you search 'trouble with pizza
dough'.
I bet you will find a whole group of supportive
people who you can talk about your troubles
with pizza dough.
But you can also get some suggestions.
So, the thing I learned from looking up mayonnaise
is that if you add few--.
If your mayonnaise breaks, which is what it's
called when it falls apart, it just looks
like eggs and oil.
Doesn't look like anything else.
You slowly add drop by drop a little bit of
water.
And you whisk and whisk and whisk and it brings
it back to life.
And it fixed it and I felt a lot better.
And I bet there's a solution with pizza dough.
While we're talking about pizza dough can
you tell me what goes wrong?
>>male #6: It usually just ends up bready
than pizza doughy.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: More bready than pizza
doughy?
>> male #6: Yeah.
It's like it's too thick.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: OK.
>> male #6: It's not like New York pizza.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: Here's the deal.
So, first of all you may be using a little
too much flour.
The other thing is the difference between
a puffy piece of white dough, bread dough,
or bread.
And then pizza dough is that there's more
gluten in pizza dough.
I know where in a war on gluten or something
right now.
But you need to probably knead it more or
leave it in your stand up mixer for longer
because--.
>> male #6: I've tried everything.
I've done it by hand.
I've done it in the Kitchen Aide mixer.
I brought a bread maker.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: Oh.
>> male #6: It's just I am not able to slay
this dragon.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: Well, you should try my
recipe for sure.
[laughter]
I mean, really, I read is the thing I hear
most from people that it works from them.
So, that's one.
But the other thing is that maybe, or even
if it's not my recipe, maybe try a few different
recipes.
Where--.
Which recipe are you using?
>> male #6: Again, all.
[laughs]
>> Gabi Moskowitz: All?
>> male #6: Yeah I just go online and you
know.
But.
Unfortunately I'm trying to duplicate a New
York style pizza.
Which is probably--
>> Gabi Moskowitz: OK.
>> male #6: I think that's pretty--.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: Well here's another thing
to think about.
You may not be rolling it out thinly enough
when you bake the pizza.
Because they--.
You ever watch them in pizza restaurants they
roll them out, it's like super thin.
Because there's yeast in it, it puffs up a
little bit.
So, that may be an issue.
>> male #6: How long do you let yours rest?
Is it-- can you make it the same day?
>> Gabi Moskowitz: What's that?
>> male #6: Do you really let it set overnight
or do you--.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: Oh no, no, no.
I only do a short rise.
I'll do two short rises like two 25 to 30
minute short rises and that seems to work.
It is kind of cool to, after you've made it,
put it in a oiled Ziploc bag and leave it
in the fridge.
And what happens is the flavor develops over
time so that's really great.
Another good trick to make it thin without
breaking it is to take a bowl like this and
flip it over and lightly flour it and put
your stretched out dough on top.
Which will help it maintain its shape and
keep it thin without breaking it.
'Cause it can be sort of hard to pull when
you pull by hand.
>>male #6: Is there an 800 help line?
>> Gabi Moskowitz: [laughs] it’s a 900 line
actually.
[laughter]
>> male presenter: I was hoping you could
talk a little bit about your experience actually
starting your blog and working with your blog
and using social media to promote it.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: Sure.
Sure.
So, I did not plan to be a food blogger.
It was not the game plan.
I got a degree from Emerson College in Theater
Education.
Got a job right out of college teaching kindergarten.
And it was great.
It was really fun.
And after about three years, I got to a point
where I started to feel like maybe wasn't
what I wanted to do for the rest of my life.
So, I started thinking about what it is I
did want to do.
And I--.
One of my favorite things to do in the classroom
had been cooking with the kids.
Because it was a great way to teach reading.
I'd have them read the recipes.
Science, we’d talk about how yeast works,
how baking soda works.
Things like that.
And math because there's if we were doubling
the recipe they'd have to figure that out.
And sharing.
And also a greater understanding of where
food comes from and what goes into cooking
and buying food and things like that.
So, and I did wanna continue teaching in some
way.
So, I kind of started, it was a funny idea
that developed into an actual business.
This catering business.
I would cater parties and I would also do
a lot of teaching.
I would teach people how to cook basic things.
I would do cooking classes for kids.
I would do cooking parties.
And it was really fun and much more lucrative
than teaching.
And it was great.
And that was going OK.
And then a friend of mine and I started talking
about this trend we were noticing where all
our friends were having a hard time managing
to feed themselves well.
So, we--.
I had been writing a BlogSpot blog and it
was called, “out of the pantry."
It's still up there.
Gabi Moskowitz dot com.
And it was like it a combination of personal
stories and recipes and drawing comparison
between cooking and personal stories and things
like that.
And so I made the leap into blogging solely
about food.
And to my utter shock and surprise, two weeks
after I launched, MSN Money ran a story about
us.
And all of a sudden we went from a few hundred
hits to 30 thousand overnight for a week or
so.
And so I very quickly determined that I needed
to monetize this thing and I managed to get
some ads.
I work with SAY Media who are fantastic.
And I also got syndicated.
So, there are a variety of newspapers and
websites and magazines that run my content
regularly.
And it took about a year, but I got to a point
where I could leave my day job and blog full
time.
And in January of 2011, yeah 2011, a publishing
house, Egg and Dart, reached out to me and
offered me a book deal.
So, I feel unbelievably fortunate to get to
do the thing I love the most for a living.
And it's thrilling and tons of fun.
And it's--.
I can't wait to find out what's gonna happen
next.
So, that's sort of the journey.
>> male #7: Hi.
So, my question is more about tools in the
kitchen.
So, you've talked a lot about the ingredients
you put into your food but for somebody that's
a beginner cook, they probably need to know
how to have things like knives, cutting boards.
Can you talk a little bit about what are some
basic things you should have in the kitchen?
>> Gabi Moskowitz: The favorite things to
have in the kitchen?
>> male #7: Like tools.
>> male #8: Basics.
> Gabi Moskowitz: Basics.
OK.
So, one of the things I recommend people have,
once you've got your basic stuff, your knife,
your cutting board, a few simple pots and
pans.
I always tell people "go to Target or Bed
Bath and Beyond and get one of the kits."
There are these sets that come with--.
Won't cost you that much particularly if you
remember, like I never do, to bring your Bed
Bath and Beyond coupon.
[laughter]
That just comes with all the basics.
Good cutting board, good knife.
Salt and pepper shakers that kind of thing.
An immersion blender.
Particularly if you have a small kitchen,
and you don't have a lot of space to work
with and you don't have a lot of money to
spend, buy a small--.
An immersion blender for 40 or 50 bucks.
Again, slightly less if you remember the coupon.
It's great for making soups directly in the
pot.
Once you start making soups that way, you
will never bother to pour hot liquid into
a food processor or blender again.
It's so much better.
But the other thing is they typically come
with a few different attachments.
So, mine came with a little chopper attachment.
So, it's like one of those mini Cuisinarts.
So, the attachment, the base of the immersion
blender fits on to the chopper attachment
and I can chop ginger, garlic, onions.
Anything.
It's great for making hummus or pesto.
Any sort of paste-like dip.
And that's really great.
It also comes with a whisk attachment which
is excellent for making whipped cream.
Or beating egg whites if you were going to
make a soufflé or something like that.
Or even just if you're making say, omelets
for lots of people and your arm is getting
tired from whisking and whisking and whisking.
That's a great tool to have.
And it also comes with a cup that like about
this big and you can place the whole immersion
blender into it.
And that's really great for making smoothies
or margaritas or things like that.
So, I would say that is just so much value
in that little tool that I highly recommend
that.
You know it's always good to have two or three
good wooden spoons.
Some rubber scrapers, a good pancake flipper
which you can use for just about anything.
Tongs are great.
A really nice tip for shopping for this kind
of stuff by the way, if you don't go to Target,
is to go to a restaurant supply store.
Because even if you don't get the discount,
usually you have to have a business I.D. number
to get a full discount.
But even if you don't get the discount, you’re
still gonna be able to find the products there
for a whole lot less money than if you were
buying them at Sur La Table or something like
that.
>> male #9: If you've taught a lot of beginners,
you must have seen some of the same mistakes
over and over again.
Can you help us avoid those pitfalls?
>> Gabi Moskowitz: Sure, sure.
Well a really important thing is, whenever
you're working with hot chilies, wash your
hands.
Or if you're working with the veins, these
are red bell peppers, but you can even see
here, all peppers have this white vein.
Don't touch it with your hands if you can
avoid it.
And definitely don't touch your girlfriend
with your hands after you touch it.
So, that's really important.
Really the number one thing, the number one
thing that gets people in trouble in the kitchen
is a lack of confidence.
They get all bogged down.
You don't see people in the kitchen just blazing
forward.
Very rare to see that kind of thing.
It's more--.
It more tends to be that people feel like
they can't do something.
So, they reread the recipe a hundred times.
And while that's happening their sauce burns
or something like that.
Or really it's OK, but people feel like it's
not.
So, there are, like I was saying before, there
are solutions out there that are really readily
available for most common kitchen problems.
But the number one solution is to know that
if you're working with--.
This is not brain surgery.
If you're working with fresh ingredients and
you're not trying to flambé everything, it's
probably gonna turn out pretty well.
And if it doesn't, you're the only one who
is gonna know.
So, just accept the compliments when they
come.
But yeah, I can't really think of anything
that's like a major no-no that people do all
the time.
I've seen kinds of silly things like, I had
a roommate who refrigerated red wine because
she thought it goes bad.
So, I had to explain it's fermented and it's
not gonna go bad.
I guess a really common kitchen mistake is,
and it's really a financial mistake also,
is that people let their food particularly
in their vegetable bin go bad.
And if you, it happens a lot when people have
a CSA box and don't really go through and
use everything regularly.
And that's just basically taking money and
putting it in the compost bin.
So, I really advise people to only buy what
they're gonna use and really make a point
to use it.
>> male #10: Yeah, do you have any favorite
radio food shows?
There's a whole bunch of good food shows on
the radio.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: On the radio?
>>male #10: Yeah.
>> Gabi Moskowitz: there's this great one
out of Sonoma County called," Dining Around
with Gene Burns" I think his name is.
And he's a really fun host.
And he talks about, he talks to different
food specialists, he goes to different restaurants.
He's pretty cool.
Yeah, I would probably say that's my favorite
one.
I don't listen to a ton of radio.
But you're right there are a lot of really
good ones out there.
Thank you.
[applause]